we ask all those who stand against the
war to vote with us
to vote for the draft
entitled humanitarian consequences of
the aggression against ukraine
it will send a powerful message aimed at
contributing to a breakthrough in
humanitarian action on the ground and
making the aggressor stop its unprovoked
war
we are encouraged by the growing number
of countries who resolutely support
asca's sponsors
this truly cross-regional draft that
gives the assembly a chance to speak
with a powerful voice
so needed to give peace a chance
the intention of the initiators and car
sponsors of the draft resolution is to
ensure the words are translated into
prompt actions on the ground
it will be critical to prevent a
spillover effect for the entire world
that is why the tax also mentions the
impact of the conflict on food security
globally
in light of the tragedy that is
unfolding that just the general assembly
has to take its responsibility and to
address this humanitarian catastrophe
and urgently call on russia to respect
the basic principles of international
humanitarian law that applies to
everyone we need a general assembly
resolution which accurately reflects the
situation and its causes
which urges the respect of the most
basic humanitarian principles that all
states have signed up to
we also need the general assembly to
come together in unity and solidarity
with the people of ukraine and in
defending the u.n charter and
international humanitarian law
the resolution presented by ukraine and
a large cross-regional group of
countries addresses not only the most
acute situation in ukraine but also
calls for protection of all those
fleeing the war without discrimination
is
technical
foreign